Hello.
And people that get the internet wherever you are. It is nine, nine, 2020.
That's right. September 9th, 2020. And this is the Rubin report.
Direct message. I give you two or three,
possibly four stories in about 24 minutes. And then you move on with your life.
That's how we're doing it. Uh, we've got a bunch today. We've got four.
Although two of them, I'm going to kind of package.
You're going to watch me package two stories into one story.
So you can pretend it's three, but if you need it to be four,
cause it's technically four that's for you to decide, uh,
there's a lot going on in the world, uh, real quick before I start, you know,
when I decided to do this show and I was talking to the blaze guys about doing
sort of a semi daily news show and everything.
One of the things that I was worried about is, as I always tell you guys,
I don't want to just add to the craziness,
make everybody angry at all that stuff.
And I was worried that if I do a daily thing and I've been saying this for
years, actually I've said this on my interview show for years and years.
And in many other interviews that one of the problems is everyone does all of
these daily shows where they're like, Oh,
I have to find 15 stories to talk about.
Then we got to clip them 800 different ways.
We got to get everybody lost in the algorithmic ClickHole of YouTube,
or just making sure that they're watching our show for an absolute hour at
night, if it's cable news, whatever it might be.
And that that in and of itself keeps us all sort of as the hamster in the wheel.
And we're just running, running, running all the time,
always looking for more stuff and we never stop and relax. Uh,
what I found in just the,
what four or five times that I've now done this new direct message show is that
you can kind of pick a couple of things in the morning that are decent,
that aren't going to make everybody crazy. And I think you can do them in,
in a pretty decent way. So here we go. Number one, I think this is good news.
I think if you're not a partisan crazy lunatic,
you might think that this is good news. Uh,
Donald Trump has been nominated for the Nobel peace prize.
Now that seems good because the word peace is attached to it.
And it would seem that maybe he did something that was a pro piece.
I'm already seeing tweets that, uh, you know, that's not the case. This is,
this is the ultimate insult to the fame Nobel prize,
which of course Barack Obama got like the day he became president,
even though he had accomplished absolutely nothing.
That was not a white power symbol, by the way,
that was just as we used to this used to be like a, just zero sorta thing or,
okay. Um,
but Donald Trump has been nominated for the Nobel peace prize, uh,
by a Norwegian lawmaker. Uh,
this is a guy who's in a right wing party.
It must be a scary right wing party in Norway. His name is Ty,
bring Getty. I believe I'm pronouncing that correctly. Uh,
and he wrote in his novel.
Nation letter that as it is expected,
other meat middle Eastern countries will follow in the footsteps of the UAE,
the United Arab Emirates.
This agreement could be a game changer that will turn the middle East into a
region of COVID.
Operation and prosperity. So before I go any further with what he said,
what he's talking about is in August Israel and the United Arab Emirates
signed, uh, at least some version of a peace accord, they're now having,
uh, travel between the countries and trade and things like that.
There's an absolutely incredible video that I've seen on Twitter.
I'm sure many of you seen it too with Benjamin Netanyahu,
the prime minister of Israel,
speaking to an official in the United Arab Emirates.
They're on the phone and they're speaking Hebrew, they're laughing.
Like you can tell something decent happening here.
We're also being told that in the last couple of weeks,
there's talks now for several other countries, maybe four or five,
four or five other Gulf nations to sign deals with Israel.
I thought this is what everybody wanted. You know, it's funny when I,
when I came back on the grid and I did my show with Michael Knowles, uh,
he listed out like the 20 things that I missed. And in a certain respect,
we kind of glossed over, uh, the Israel Arab country,
Gulf country peace agreements here, because it was like,
there was so much going on. And what he said was that, well,
actually the media kind of ignored it.
And that in many ways gets to the heart of what is wrong with so much of what's
going on in the world right now. It's like, if something that we all wanted,
right? Like everybody, I thought the thing that everybody wanted,
the thing that can never happen,
that we all want is that we want peace in the middle East and nobody can do it.
And there's been a million deals they've tried to have,
and they've had agreements and they've had a cords and they've had meetings and
everybody's gone to camp David and they signed things and nothing ever happens.
Uh, but now it actually seems that there's been some sort of realignment in the
middle East.
It seems like there's been some sort of tectonic shift that alliances are
actually changing and maybe the old Wars of the
last century,
maybe they won't happen anymore because countries are realizing, Oh,
that little tiny piece of land, the size of New Jersey that has no oil.
Those guys w maybe they're not that all that terrible.
But I thought that was something that we all wanted. And it's like, if you look,
if you just look right now on what the pundits are saying,
it's like either they're ignoring the original deal with the, uh,
UAE in Israel, or they're trying to minimize it. Uh,
but this Norwegian lawmaker who I'm sure is going to have a zillion hit pieces
written about him any day now should be,
by the time I finished speaking the sentence, uh, he feels.
Otherwise he went on to say that, uh,
that Trump's key role in facilitating contact between conflicting parties
and creating new dynamics and other protracted conflicts,
such as the cashmere border dispute between India and Pakistan and the conflict
between North and South Korea,
as well as dealing with the nuclear capabilities of North Korea.
All basically make Trump worthy of the nomination.
Now that does seem legit.
So let's try to remember move partisan politics from this for a second and just
deal with reality. Let's assume for a second,
if we're to believe any of these things that the middle East is shifting a
little more towards peace,
that there doesn't seem to be this feeling that there's going to be suddenly a
war breaking out there. I don't think anyone really feels that. I mean,
there's still some stuff with Iran,
but I don't think anyone really feels there's suddenly going to be a war.
I think part of that is that people don't know what Trump will do now.
His critics would say, Oh, that's because Trump's crazy.
And he's got his finger on the button and the whole world could blow up tomorrow
in world war three. I think it's actually a type of strategy that you go, Oh,
you know,
we've got a pretty big army and you don't know what we're going to do with it.
Uh, that used to be called deterrence, right?
That's what you get taught in political science. You have deterrence,
you have a big army. Sometimes you threaten people. Sometimes you don't,
but you keep a little bit of elements of surprise to keep your enemies sorta on
their toes.
So right now it doesn't seem like there's going to be any sort of middle East
war. Um,
he also referenced that North and South Korea seem to be heading a little bit
towards peace. We've seen a little bit of that, right?
We saw the very awkward walk that Trump took with Kim Jong-un. I mean,
we've seen that something decent seems to be happening there. Uh,
the cashmere area between Pakistan and India, uh,
we haven't heard too much about that,
but I don't sense that a war is breaking out.
Like it does seem that the world is shifting a little bit,
maybe the days of giant, you know, ground invasion Wars are ending.
And this will actually get me to the,
to the next story that I'm combining with this one.
So this all seems good, right?
These are all the things that I thought we wanted. Uh,
and if Barack Obama can get a Nobel peace prize for doing nothing,
then it sorta seems to me that, yeah,
Trump is at least worthy of nomination. I'd love to hear your thoughts on this,
though. If, if you disagree with me,
let me know in the comments right down below.
And this actually shifts me to the, to the second part of this story.
When I said we had three or four, depending on which way you look at it, uh,
this story is just breaking right now, but Trump has announced,
or it has leaked at least that there is going to be a further troop withdrawal,
uh, in Iraq. Now, again, I think this is a good thing, right? What did we want?
We wanted troops out of Iraq. We can debate all day long,
whether you thought the Iraq war was good, we can debate all day long,
whether they were on the path to democracy.
And then we pulled out our troops too soon.
Let's not forget they were having basically free and fair elections.
And then Obama did do what he said he was going to do,
which was just get our troops out quickly.
And then basically the country fell apart again. Then we had the surge, blah,
blah, blah, blah. Okay. Uh, it seems to me that at this point,
whether you were for the war, Oregon, to the war,
that we don't need a zillion troops on the ground in Iraq, uh,
it looks like only after this withdrawal, if,
and this is all sort of happening right now. So some of this stuff could change,
but it looks like after this boot draw, we'll only have 5,200 troops Interac.
That seems pretty good. And we, of course you can debate, well,
should we have 4,000? Should we have 10,000?
Where are they going to be deployed? Are we keeping them in the Gulf?
We can talk about all of those things. But scaling back from these Wars,
I think is what the left used to want, right? Wasn't the left always saying, Oh,
it's the conservatives and the Republicans and the neo-cons,
those are the scariest, uh, that are, that want all the war.
And yet Trump is now pulling us back from those Wars. Interestingly,
Tulsi Gabard, who I've had on the show.
Who's a democratic Congresswoman from Hawaii and a veteran she's
actively in the military actually. Um,
she was completely anti war and she was totally rejected
by the democratic establishment, right. She had a lot of underground support.
It was very obvious to me.
She had a lot of underground support during the primaries,
but then in effect, the party just pretty much ignored her.
And even when she hadn't even withdrawn,
they weren't putting in putting her in debates and they did what they do.
We time and again,
when they've screwed Bernie and they've screwed other people where they suddenly
change what the qualifications are to get in debates and the rest of it.
So it's a little hard to tell if you, well, let's put it this way.
If you think that the old idea of Republicans want war and Democrats want
peace, if you think that's the prism that we should be looking at these things,
then you're very confused at the moment because I think most people,
most Americans.
Uh, don't want war.
Would like us to wrap up these things, do it as responsibly as possible,
and then leave the lamb to the people that live there.
So I think that leaving Iraq is good. Oh, wait, let's not forget.
He's also getting us out of that Afghanistan thing,
which people don't believe this, but the Afghanistan war.
Which started.
Obviously after nine 11, which is it's the,
what's the 19th anniversary of nine 11, and just two days from now, which is,
which is just incredible. And I'll talk a little bit more about that.
I was in New York city, uh, during nine 11. And it was, uh,
that was beyond imagination. I'll talk a little bit more about that tomorrow.
Um, but you know, we've.
Been in the Afghanistan war for about 18, 19 years.
It's the longest war in American history.
It's hard to really understand that or, or even believe it when you say that,
right? Because it doesn't feel like a war.
Like we don't know really why we're there. We were getting the Taliban out.
And what, and then it.
Just kind of went on and went on and went on and it went on for Bush and it went
on for Obama. And Trump is trying to scale that back. These are good things.
That's all I'm trying to tell you whether,
whether you like Trump or hate Trump us, you know,
I think partly what's happened here is that so many people make their decisions
on whatever Trump thinks. So if you love Trump and you make a decision,
it's automatically good. And if you hate Trump and he makes a decision,
it's automatically bad. You, you can't look at the world like that. You know,
you have to be for something, not just be against someone.
And I think too many people, especially in the media do that.
So now you're going to see people sort of jumping through hoops to basically
explain why leaving AraC or Afghanistan is bad.
You're going to probably start seeing a lot of that on MSNBC and the
left-leaning places because they can't give Trump credit because what have they
said about the guy the entire time that he's Hitler and you could watch,
I recommend you guys try to find it.
There's a video that I did the day after the 2016 election, we were at our,
our old place and we were building the Rubin report studio.
So I didn't even have a studio. So I'm, um, I forget if I was using my computer,
my laptop or my phone, I think it was off a phone.
And I'm just sitting in the backyard and you can actually hear construction
inside. And one of the things that I kept saying was look,
everyone's surprised Trump is president. Okay.
Even if you were a huge Trump supporter, you were surprised Trump was president.
People are freaking out. They're going crazy. People are young people,
women screaming. I mean, all hell was breaking loose,
but what you guys could do right now,
and this is what I've tried to get the left to do for,
for a while is a little bit of self-reflection. You might want to go,
you know, we've been calling this guy Hitler and his supporters
Nazis, and it's really not what you're doing to them. When you do that,
it's not what you're doing to Trump. It's doing,
it's what you're doing to yourself, because you can never be like, Oh,
that guy I've been calling Hitler and all those Nazis around,
they're actually starting to do good work.
And I think that is why the craziness gets ramped up because you can't have
people that for three years were calling him, Hitler suddenly go, Oh,
Hitler's doing good stuff. This,
this is sort of a psychological trap that they're,
that they're locked in at the moment. So anyway,
I think there's a lot of good stuff happening right here. And,
and we have this sort of get through the brush to understand it.
We are heading towards a place not to say that there will be pure,
perfect middle East peace, but it starts with some economic agreements.
It starts with some travel. It starts with some phone calls.
And the truth is Trump has something to do with some of that stuff.
Getting out of Iraq is good. Getting out of Afghanistan is good. And, uh,
and we shall see if he wins the Nobel prize.
And speaking of prizes, watch that for a segue. Uh, the Oscars,
remember Hollywood,
Hollywood used to be a place where they made things called movies and, uh,
they made TV shows and other forms of entertainment.
And what they would do is they would generally hire people who were capable of
acting in these movies or writing in these movies and they would then create
something. And then we would go to the movie theater or to, uh,
turn on our television and we'd watch these forms of entertainment.
And perhaps we laugh or we'd cry, or some other emotion would pop up.
And that's what Hollywood was there for. Hollywood is just a business.
People like to think that Hollywood is this sort of, uh,
that it's this like obelisk or something, this thing that exists.
And it has this perfect set of rules. And, and that, that is what it is.
But Hollywood is just a business it's in the business of entertainment.
And what are businesses? Businesses are trying to make money. Well,
unfortunately, Hollywood, which has been one of the prime purveyors of wokeness,
they've decided to go fully stupid woke. And, uh,
now the Oscars are going to have woke points in
effect. Uh, social justice has completely,
if you thought that there was any version of Hollywood that hasn't been corroded
by all of this nonsense.
It's here, people it's absolutely here, there are.
Our new Oscar standards, uh,
to require best pictures to be inclusive.
So we're going to pull up an image here and I'm going to read some of this
stuff. It's, it's just, it's absolutely incredible.
But of course it's not surprising.
So standard a, which is about on-screen representation,
themes, and narratives now.
To achieve a standard, a rating so that you can win.
In the Oscar. That means that the film must meet one of the following criteria,
a one,
a lead or a significant SU lead or significant supporting
actors.
And what they're talking about here is that means that a leader or a significant
amount of supporting actors,
at least one of the lead actors or significant supporting actors is from an
underrepresented racial or ethnic group. Now this includes Asian.
It includes Hispanic or Latin X.
By the way, no Latin or Latino person says the phrase,
Latin X. That is something only that social justice warriors forced them to do.
And they don't know why.
And it's very confusing. Usually white lefties.
Uh, you've got to have black or African-Americans.
Indigenous slash native American slash Alaskan native middle
Eastern slash North African native, Hawaiian,
or other Pacific Islander or other underrepresented race or
ethnicity. So that's true.
A one. So now first off,
what we're saying is you have to have a certain amount of these types of people
based on the color of their skin or their ethnicity to, uh,
to possibly get that coveted Oscar. Now, this is, uh,
what we would call complete and utter nonsense that if you were doing a movie
about the mafia, let's say, let's say you were doing, I mean,
I could pick any mafia movie, but the, the, to me, the, the best is Goodfellas,
right? So Goodfellas was about the mafia and, uh,
it was about the Italian mafia and it took place in the eighties.
And the Italian mafia had a lot of,
you're not going to believe this Italian people, uh, around them.
And they were making the gravy and all that good stuff and killing some people.
There happened to be a lot of white people in the film. Uh,
they were mostly Italian. Most of the actors were Italian, not all of them, uh,
but there were mostly white people in film. You may remember that. Um,
what's his name? Who's that actor who was a mace Windu who's the actor.
Michael B after mace. Windu what's the,
what the hell is the freaking guy's name? He's a huge actor. What's his name?
Frigging Samuel L. Jackson, Jesus come back. Um, Samuel L.
Jackson was in it for about three minutes. Okay. Now he happens to be black,
but I guess that wouldn't be enough because that would just be one black guy.
He was only in it for a few minutes. Now,
putting aside the stupidity of all that you can already see,
everyone knows why this is nonsense.
Do you want to judge your actors skills or your writer's skills or
anything else or, or anyone forget your actors or your, your, your writers,
anyone, your doctor let's remove the Oscars for just a second.
Let's say you had a heart problem and you're going for heart surgery.
Would you want the best doctor,
or would you want the best doctor who happened to be gay or Latin X
or Latin X sounds like a type of mutant or a,
or whatever it might be is which would you want.
Or, and call me crazy. Would you.
Not care about your doctors, gender, or sexuality or skin color?
And if you were going for heart surgery, you would just say, Hey, can I,
can I get the best doctor or do you, are you good at what you do? Could,
could you do my surgery?
I don't care whether he gets sleep with the dude or not. That's what you want,
but, but they have done this all down and it gets done.
Let's just continue, uh, a two. So that was just the rules for a one,
a two are about the general ensemble cast,
at least 30% of all actors in secondary or more
minor roles are from at least two of the following underrepresented groups.
Women are women underrepresented in Hollywood. If we took the entire,
the entire thing that Hollywood is all of the movies,
all of the TV show it's are women way less underrepresented.
Usually you watch a show. There's some women in it.
There's some men who's counting.
Uh, but you've got to have, uh, racial or ethnic groups,
LGBTQ plus I'm still a little confused what the plus is, uh,
people with cognitive or physical disabilities or who are
deaf or.
We're hard of hearing. So I guess kiss off blind people.
You're not on the list, sorry, blind people, but deaf people.
We're going to get a whole bunch of you in there. You hear that, uh,
a three is that the main.
Story or subject matter, and this is of all the stupid ones.
This is peak stupidity, right?
Uh,
the main storyline theme or narrative of the film should be centered on
[inaudible] should be centered on an underrepresented group.
This includes women racial or ethnic group,
LGBTQ plus people with cognitive or physical disabilities,
or who are deaf or hard of hearing.
This is stupidity people. This is absolute stupidity. Oh,
and the best part of all of this, all of these rules,
which apparently are extremely important.
And they're going to end racism and bring the quality, all of this.
They're not implying ending until 2024, because you know,
you don't have to do a lot of stuff to make sure that the stuff in the can,
that's waiting to come out over the next couple of years, we would,
they have to get rid of all of that old school racist stuff that they're about
to throw on us, all the stuff that's waiting to get on Netflix and on Hulu.
It's, it's just the height of stupidity. It's why social justice,
which sounds sort of right. Again,
if you don't think about all of this and you just hear this,
or we're going to have more gay people and black people and Latin X people and
deaf people we're, if we're going to have more of these people in everything,
uh, that things are going to be better, but just,
just doing it for the sake of those characteristics that are,
that are meaningless, doesn't make it better.
I will say one other thing before we move on, um, I,
I have a friend who's a extremely well-known sitcom actor or
actress. I'm not going to say whether it's an actor or actress, but has been,
but it's very famous. And it's been in several shows over decades.
And this person told me that in their last show, which only had a brief stint,
because it did not go well that in the writer's room,
they in effect decided that they weren't hiring people based on whether they
were funny or not. This person's a comic actor or actress, uh,
that they decided they were going to say, Oh, we're going to,
we have to have one gay person. We have to have one Indian person.
We have to have one black person, one Asian person, et cetera, et cetera.
And that what you got in there was that in effect is not only did you say that
the number one thing to write a comedy show is not to be funny,
but you get a whole bunch of people who then have all sorts of,
they use that identity and then fight over what the storylines will be and
everything else. And the last show that this person did was,
was an absolute disaster and miserable for him or her.
So it ruins everything and it ruins every institution it comes in and
it's, it's ruining Hollywood. When's the last time you saw something good.
I mean, all of us right now, we're trapped at home and what happens.
You're on Apple TV, you're on Netflix and it doesn't end.
You can't even find anything worth watching. I'm watching, um, chef's table,
the barbecue edition. That's pretty good actually,
because those people had skills and I don't care whether the guy who's giving me
barbecue is black or white or gay or straight or a lesbian or death. Okay.
And one story I'm going to do real quick, quick, uh, CNN,
have you heard of that? Uh, former news network? Um,
well they put a, a, they did a little piece,
like an hour long piece on Joe Biden and it was called fight for the white
house, Joe Biden's long journey. And you know,
the guy has been in politics for 263 years. So it is a long journey.
And one of the things they did, let's throw up the images. They showed image.
Let's show the original image. First, an image.
You can see it right now of Joe Biden with his son.
And they're at a Redskins game and his son is wearing a Redskins
hat. Now the Redskins used to be a football team.
You remember football before everyone stopped watching. Uh,
but CNN felt that that was too offensive, apparently.
So they edited out the Washington Redskins logo.
They didn't mention that they did it. And then they aired the photo this way,
without the deeply offensive red skins logo.
Now this story, the reason I wanted to just hit on this real quick,
it's not that important in the scheme of things, right? Middle East peace,
perhaps more important, but this type of story,
where a news organization decides to edit out something,
whether you're for the Redskins, keeping their name or you're against it,
whether you think it's offensive. And usually it's, again,
it's white lefties who are offended by this generally not native Americans,
whether you're for it or against it or whatever it is, it existed.
This idea that we can erase history. Let's tear down monuments.
Let's edit out logos on hats. All of these things,
these are deeply dangerous ideas. They could have shut. Well, first of all,
they didn't have to show the picture at all. So someone,
there was some thought process at CNN where a producer and an AP and an
editor, everybody got together and they said, okay,
this is the picture of Biden. And we want to show it.
Then somebody in the name of social justice said,
we must edit out that picture of the Redskins because they don't exist now
because we're so tolerant, we've got to get rid of it. And then they just said,
we're okay, we're going to do it. We're not going to make, you know,
they could've made a commentary on it. They could've put a little disclaimer,
something, but they do nothing.
And the point of the story and why I wanted to hit on is when they do these
little manipulations,
you've got to wonder what the far bigger manipulations are.
So I thought it was a story worth, worth noting. I'm sorry.
If we showed you the image and you were, you were deeply, deeply offended.
We should have put a trigger warning before the show.
I will talk to my team about that and I will probably fire at least three
people, preferably white ones. This was the Rubin report.
Direct message for September 9th, 2010.
[Inaudible].